in Kingdom Come deliverance there are a
multitude of mechanics to understand and
master at times the game alludes to them
but the majority of the time you're left
to figure them out on your own through
experimentation with so many veiled
intricacies and secrets we've compiled
tips to help you on your journey through
the medieval kingdom of Bohemia as you
expect food is an essential resource to
have on your all times
but like real food it can go stale and
eventually become rotten with the
exception of dried meats and fruits but
otherwise every crust of bread and stray
Apple you collects will turn rotten if
you're not paying attention so keep an
eye on the appropriate meter when
browsing your inventory for a bite to
eat if you slip up and eat some bad eggs
you can develop food poisoning and the
last thing you need when you're wearing
full plate Armour is a dippy tummy
saving often may seem like a trivial
thing to point out for a guide like this
but during our first few hours of the
game we were shocked with how paramount
is to do so
Kingdom Come is prone to occasional
quest breaking bugs so saving at regular
intervals ensures you'll only have to
backtrack a few minutes should something
force you to read Oh to save if you're
wealthy enough to afford them or you're
adept alchemy you can get some savior
snaps drinking these means you should
have no problem saving whenever you're
feeling satisfied with your progress but
otherwise keep a mental map of nearby
beds so you can easily save for free
whenever you feel the time is just right
although don't overdo the save by Sleep
method Henri is only allowed so many
hours of sleep per day and you may need
those hours for healing purposes just PC
players if savings getting you down you
guys can just download this mod that
allows infinite saves sorry console
players
when battling foes kitted out in play
armor you'll notice that sharp blades
are generally ineffective that is unless
you're strategically targeting the
unprotected areas like for arms legs and
faces that just won't work when there
are times when you're facing enemies
that are decked out in plate from head
to toe in these moments you'll be better
off using a blunt weapon instead like a
mace or a Warhammer against a plated out
knight it will deal far more damage than
any sharp blade
if you're approaching an enemy try
peppering them with arrows before they
notice you if you're lucky or just a
skilled I'll show you could take one
with a shot to the eye especially if
they don't have helmet while his friends
run up on you also you can quickly
damage foot soldiers with handheld
weapons while on horseback for example
you can fire an arrow an enemy while
continually keeping your distance from
them these tactics might not be the most
flashy but they can be effective during
the beginning when you lack the
equipment needed to stand a chance if
you want to increase your odds of
survival and battle keeping your sword
sharp is essential to sharpen your blade
head to any blacksmith and look for
nearby grindstone the directions will
vary depending on the control scheme
you're using but you need to keep the
angle and pressure on the sweet spot
you're looking to make sparks to keep
your weapon sharp if you're seeing smoke
slowdown you're doing more damage to
your blade once it's clean and shiny
well head out and make it dirty all over
again if you want to ender acumen or a
bandit camp without being attacked try
stealing the armor and posing as one of
them however be careful they don't get
suspicious if they ask you what's going
on and you haven't learned their
language they'll easily see through your
disguise keep your interactions few and
far between while in disguise and only
commit to the crime when no one else is
watching
throughout your adventure in the kingdom
of bohemia you'll sometimes run into
scholars while they don't have much to
offer you in terms of advancing your
skills on their own they can teach you
how to read if you've got a bunch of
books accumulating in your inventory now
you can read them to acquire bonuses to
your various skills like combat and
alchemy just head to a bed or a reading
spot sit yourself down pick up a good
book and study away those are some brief
tips that should help you get by a bit
easier in bohemia' we have a video
covering the combat focus tip so make
sure you check that out if you're
struggling in fights and if you have any
tips of your own be sure to share them
in the comments thanks so much for
watching and for any more Kingdom Come
deliverance coverage stay tuned to
Gamescom
you